hello and welcome to this video see you
never know what to pronounce that Z do
load probably not
anyway so what is he doing
it's a hot water so he ultimately goes
into a stone wall - okay
ya know show me what you want to do with
your Bishop on c8 okay
[Music]
it's early it's very early b6
you
hmm okay
you
yeah I have not yet analyzed this for my
upcoming book so we hit
in an area that I'm not yet familiar
with so much
I was mostly playing Nydia 3 and C 4
tournament chess in the last couple of
years especially Knight f3 so the stone
wall never featured because the stone
wall against Nadia 3 is not really good
and just to be different but wide to
play but do mean this is some decent
enough setup I think giving like
something to think about now rook c1
maybe
why is that working it should never work
it's not like I played Bishop g5 to just
give up my bishop
okay
you
No so it's just an exchange for him but
nothing basically can almost pre-move
night I made I should maybe he gives up
the Queen or something something crazy
no I can't so take him and I'm
immediately on that night so there is no
way he takes on g5 and traps my night I
can just take so when to take on d7
save this piece and now the question is
if I should take on g5 or not
sure if it is a really cool real
question that
yeah hello tink first
95 is actually not a bad move at all
makes the black Queen move again but
it's just tempting her take another pawn
do we just take it probably
now maybe a form he doesn't want to take
and activate all my pieces on the
kingside and well if for stops any hope
for black to do something here
as too bad bishops very
new
now this bishop can be activated on h3
so yeah not a move that he wanted to
play for sure but I kind of understand
that
it feels difficult to keep both both be
sure to dead but here that should lose
for other
rather quickly under king
you
ideas just double on the FL playbook f7
you
and I don't see how he
can hold that
no yeah I mean that was kind of a No
game because we were like this is a I
think a normal normal position maybe a
theoretical position and he played age
six so no I don't know what the engine
is recommending yet wants to play the c5
c5 well it's a sharp one it's a sharp
position
you
you know I would actually think that
that what the engine is giving you is
quite comfortable for what I mean if you
look at the trade everything I've tried
everything take take take take this this
is better for white I mean no question
those pawns are all weak my position is
very compact there's no weakness at so
at all so here I would be very happy
with what he cannot do this because of
95
anyway played h6 which is blundering the
exchange and essentially the game yeah
maybe taking on a fade is a bit tougher
but it's just too much
for me taking probably accelerates the
demise but you're just material down
yeah this is not not defensible too much
everything's on the king yeah and I I'm
not sure I think this is kind of a good
setup this kind of thing you can play
but I'm not yet in a stage where I can
say I analyzed it for a couple of hours
okay guys thanks for watching